今日はこの中部経典の番目の経典になってます
名前はVitakka Santānaという Vitakka
っていうのは思考のことで Santāna
っていうのは管理ですね
思考の管理についてという経典になるんです
専門家が違う意味言うかもしれませんだけど santati
というのは何か適当に置いておくということなんですね
いわゆる整理して管理するという意味になるんです
いい加減にあっちこっちに置くという意味ではないんです
ですから この意味としては思考の整理教という風に Evaṃ
me sutaṃ. Ekāṃ samayaṃ bhagavā sāvatthiyaṃ viharati
jetavane anāthapiṇḍikassa
ārāme. Tatra kho bhagavā bhikkhu āmaṃtesi, bhikkhavo'ti.
Badante ti te bhikkhu
bhagavato paccasso'si. Bhagavā etadavoca.エワンメーすたん
このように私が聞きました
エーカンサメアン ある時
バーガワー 世尊がサーワッティヤン
サーワッティーにジェータワネ
ヴィーラティセ あの 住んでいましたと
ジェータワネアナートピンディカッサーラーメ
アナートピンディカが作った祇園精舎ジェータワナというお寺に住んでいましたと
タトレコ その時バーガワー
お釈迦様がビクウアーマンテーシ
比丘たちを呼びました
ビッキャウォー ビクラよと
比丘たちよと比丘たちを呼びましたと
バダンテーティテービクブ
バガトパッチャッソースン
バダンテー まあ尊じっていうことですね
まあ尊じという風にお釈迦様にこの返事をしましたと
バガワーエタドオーチェ
それで釈尊がこのように語りましたと Adhicittaṃ
anuyuttena, bhikkhave, bhikkhuṇā pañca nimittāni kālen
a kālaṃ manasikātabbāni
patamāni pañca. Idaṃ, bhikkhave, bhikkhuṇo yaṃ nimittaṃ āgamma yaṃ nimittaṃ
manasikaroto uppajjanti pāpakā akusalā vitakkā chando'pa
saṃhitā doso'pa saṃhitā
moho'pa saṃhitā'pi. Tena, bhikkhave, bhikkhuṇā dhamumā
nimittā aññaṃ nimittaṃ
manasikātabbaṃ kusalo'pa saṃhitaṃ. Tassa dhamumā nimitt
ā aññaṃ nimittaṃ manasikaroto
kusalo'pa saṃhitaṃ. Ye pāpakā akusalā vitakkā chando'pa
saṃhitā pi doso'pa saṃhitā
pi moho'pa saṃhitā'pi te pahīyanti te abbhattaṃ gacchanti.
Tesāṃ pānā ajhattaṃ
eva cittaṃ santikkkhati sammitīyati ekodhi hoti samādhiyati.それは一つの文章ですけど
かなり長いんです アディチッタンアヌユッテーナ
アディチッタ チッタというのは心
アディチッタっていうのは超越した心
日常生活で我々は使用している心の次元を破って
ものすごい超越した心
超越した次元という意味なんですね
その心の眼耳鼻舌身にコントロールされていて
それはどうしても乗り越えられない
普通の人間には 人間何を考えても
すべてのこの考え方の情報が
この眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報に限ってます
それ以上のことは何一つも言えません
では 人間が妄想したり
いろんなことをしたり
何言ってますかと いくら妄想ってしたっても
すべて調べてみれば 眼耳鼻舌身の情報の中でしか語ってないんです
それは仏教の立場で神の言葉を聞く人を見て
神が見える人を見て いろいろ幽霊と喋る人もいろいろいるかもしれませんだけど
それ予言する人やらね
占ってあげる人やらね
で 何をしても誰にでも超越した智慧があるというふうにはちょっと考えにくいんですね
だから その言っていることを調べてみると
すべて眼耳鼻舌身の情報の中で語れるものであります
それ以上のものっていうのはないんですね
だから 人間の思考っていうのは
ほとんどの生命の思考にしたっても
やっぱりこの目耳鼻から入る情報が頭に叩き込んで
それからいろいろ思考を働かすというか
妄想するというか そういうふうな知識なんですね
あるのは だから仏教の場合は修行して何を目指すかというと
この眼耳鼻舌身だけに限っている
この次元を破って 超越した次元に心を育ててみようではないかなというふうに努力するんですね
その努力についてアディチッテという言葉を使っているんですね
いわゆる心の次元を乗り越えようと
アヌユッテーナっていうのは
その修行に励んでいる人
ユッタっていうのは まあ今これ今よく皆様知られているヨーガという言葉から出てくる
このユッジという何かに頑張る
何かに励む何か仕事ということなんですね
そこその同じ動詞から出てくる言葉なんですね
アディチッタ・アヌユッタというのは
このアディチッタ 超越した心ということに頑張って修行している
ビクナ 比丘が 比丘がではないんですけど
ビク これはまあまあインストルメンタルですけど
まあそれは置いとってね
パンチャ・ニミッターニ
五つの事柄かな まあ対象ですけど
ニミッタっていうのは心に考える時の対象ですよ
ニミッタっていうのは特色という意味もありますし
いわゆるオブジェクト・オブ・パーセプションということで
この何を考えているかというね
例えば時計を見て 我々は時計について語ったりする場合は
時計がニミッタになるんです
いわゆる認識する時の対象ということなんですね
ニミッタというのは 五つのニミッタを
五つの認識対象というかね
カーレーナ・カーラン
まあ時々々というか 卒中というかね
まあカーレーナ・カーランというのは
まあ適当にまあ必要な時という意味にもなりますね
カーラっていうのは時間なんですね
カーレーナ・カーランという風に
このインストルメンタル・ケースを使って
またカーランというのは体格で
まあそれでこのつなげることで
だから直訳と成り立ちませんだけど
英語で言えばoccasionallyというふうにね
occasionallyというと
時々という意味でもないんですね
まあ必要な時ということでね
マヌシカータッバン 観察するべきですね
マヌシカータッバンというのはまあ考えるべきということなんですね
マヌシというのは心においてなさるべきということなんで
心に入れてするべきということで
だから考えるべきということなんですね
そこで次にカタマニ・パンチャ
この五つは何でしょうかと
だからこのこの文章はすぐつなげますけど
その一部の主語はこのパンチャ・ニミッタなんですね
五つの対象が 超越した智慧に修行する比丘に
時たま観察するべきですと
だから比丘に観察されるべきですね
というふうな このパッシブ・ボイスで書かれて
パッシブ・ボイスでもないんですけど
これはパーリ語の書き方で
この強調するものは主語にするんですね
だから比丘は主語ではありません
このポイントが大事ということで
あなた方に考えられるべきですよというふうに
これが考えられるべきですよと言って
このこれから説明する五つの方が主語にしてポイントにして置いておくんです
だから 読む人々はパーリ経典を読む場合は
決してこの個人がハイライトしないんですね
いつでも内容ポイントの方だけハイライトしているんですね
だからそれはパーリ文
パーリ語 経典のパーリ語の場合は
それはものすごく明確にあって
テキスト 普通のテキストの場合はまあ違います
まあ普通の 言葉と同じく修行があって
仏教に語ってますけど
経典の語はまたやり方が違います
経典語になってくると
やっぱりこのポイントをハイライトして
それをいつでも修行にするんですね
で カタマーニパンチ その実質は何でしょうかと
イデ・ビッケービクノ・ヤン・ニミッタ・アーガマ
ヤン・ニミッタ・マネシカロート
ウッパジャンテ・パータカ・アクサラ・ヴィタッカ
また言葉を一つ一つ説明していきます
イデというのはケース
何かケースを語るときなんですね
このケースの場合はという風にね
ビクラヨ このケースの場合はということで
ビクノ ビク その場合のビクノっていうのは
やっぱりジェネティブ複数形になってますけど
このヤン・ニミッタ・アーガマ
何か対象に アーガマっていうのは向かった時という意味
アーガマというのは来た時ということなんです
ヤン 何か対象が来た時
いわゆる心に何か浮かんだ時という意味は
心に何か浮かんだ時なんです
だからニミッタという言葉はこちらに中心的なポイントだから
それを覚えておかないと
ニミッタっていうのは認識の対象で
何かニミッタが来た時は
何か心に考え方か何か入った時は
アーガマ ヤン・ニミッタ・マネシカロート
何かニミッタをマネシカロート
心で考える時 いわゆるこれ二回言ってるんですね
意味は同じです 何か頭に入ったならばという単純な意味なんですね
何か頭に考え方が入ったならばという単純なことなんですけど
もうちょっと分けて意味を
二回言ってるんですね
何かニミッタが 対象が入った時
何かニミッタを観察・考える時と
というふうに二つにして言ってるんです
その時ウッパジャンテ
生まれてきます 何を パータカ・アクサラ・ダンマ
パータカっていうのは罪ということで
アクサラっていうのは不善ですね
パータカ・アクってあって
不善であってね 生まれていきます
パータカ・アクの あるいは不善のアクサラ
ヴィタッカ 思考が生まれてくる
だからこの場合はウッパジャンテっていうのは動詞
複数形の動詞で 主語はパータカ・アクサラ・ヴィタッカなんですね
だから悪の思考が生まれる
何か対象に出会って 何か対象が頭で考えるときは
不善な あるいは悪の思考が生まれる
そのケース それからこのヴィタッカ
思考の また形容詞が続けていくんですね
チャンドゥーパサンヒタ
チャンダっていうのはこの欲
この場合は欲のことですね
欲に関わる思考 ヒ ドースーパサンヒタ
怒りに関わる思考 あるいはモーフーパサンヒタ
無知に関わる だから不善な
悪的な思考が生まれる
その不善・悪の思考というのは
欲に関わる思考 怒りに関わる思考
あるいは無知に関わる思考だよということで
それでテーナ その時は
このケースの場合はこういうふうにしますよと
テーナ ビッケービクナ
比丘たちがこうするべきです
タンハ・ニミッタ その対象からアンニャン・ニミッタ
他の対象をマネシカ・タッバン
心に入った この何か概念が入ってしまうでしょうに
その入った概念について考えちゃうと不善が生まれてくる
その場合はすぐアンニャン・ニミッタ
違う対象をマネシカ・タッバン
考えるべきですと それはどういう違う対象かというと
クサルーパ・サンヒタ
善たる何か 他の対象をすぐ考え
入れ替えてくださいと
タッサ・タンハ・ニミッタ・アンニャン・ニミッタ・マネシカロート
彼にこのタンハ・ニミッタ
この対象ニミッタから
いわゆるこの不善たるニミッタからアンニャン・ニミッタ
他のニミッタを いわゆる善たるニミッタをマネシカロート
考えるとクサルーパ・サンヒタ
ヨー・パータカ・アクサラ・ヴィタッカ・チャンドゥーパサンヒターピ・ドースーパサンヒターピ・モーフーパサンヒターピ
それらのこの不善たる思考が
欲に関わる 怒りに関わる
無知に関わる 不善たる思考がテー・パヒーヤンティ
消えていきます なくなっていきます
アッバッタム・ガッチャンティっていうのは
どんどん沈んでなくなって消えていきますと
パヒイェティっていうのは減るという
どんどんどんどん減っていくという
アッバッタンガッチャンティっていうのは
また同じ減っていくという
まあまあ消えていくというね
テーサンパハナ これらがなくなったところで
テーサンパハナ これらっていうのはこの不善たる思考がなくなったところでアッジャッタンエーワチッタンサンティッペティ
チッタン 心がアッジャッタンエーワ
自分の中のみ 自分の修行の
まあ瞑想しているんだからね
その瞑想の中のみ サンティッペティ
落ち着いて確立してしまう
だから心はあっちこっち行かないで
この自分の修行にもう確立して安定して置いておきます
ナッティマン サンニシーデティっていうのは
よくもす よく座るっていうことですよ
いわゆるもう瞑想修行中だから
この修行の対象について心がよく落ち着いて
リラックスして安定しておきますということなんですね
エーコーディホーティ
統一性 一境性になります
瞑想対象と サマーディヤティ
サマーディが生まれていきます
サマーディも生じますと
定も生まれると それを明確に説明するために
またたとえ また入ってくるんですね
セ
ッイェターピ・ビッケーヴェー・ダッコー・パララ・ガンドー・ワー・パララ・ガンダン・テーワー・シーワー・スクマーヤーニヤー・オーラーリ・カンハーニン・アビ
ニーハネーヤ・アビニーハレーヤ・アビニワッジェーヤ・テーワ・メーワ・コー・ビッケーヴェー・ビックーノー・ヤン・ニミッタング・アーガッマ・ヤン・ニミッタ
ム・マナシカロー・トー・ウッパッジャンティ・パープカー・アティ・サラ・ヴィタッカー・チャンドー・ウパサンヒターピ・ドーソー・ウパサンヒターピ・モーホー
・ウパサンヒターピ・テーナ・ビッケーヴェー・ビックーナ・タン・ハー・ニミッタング・アンニャン・ニミッタム・マナシカー・タン・バン・クサ・ルーパ・サンヒ
タン・タッサ・タン・ハー・ニミッタ・アンニャン・ニミッタム・マナシカロー・トー・クサ・ルーパ・サンヒタン・イエー・パープカー・アティ・サラ・ヴィタッカー
・チャンドー・ウパサンヒターピ・ドーソー・ウパサンヒターピ・モーホー・ウパサンヒターピ・テー・パヒーヤンティ・テー・アッバッタン・ガッチャンティ・テー
・サンパーナ・アッジャッタン・エーワ・チッタン・サンティッペティ・サンニシーデティ・エーコーディ・ホーティ・サマーディヤティ
とにかくこの暗記するための暗記の経典ですから
このポイントは何回も繰り返しておくんですね
だからもう強烈にこのヴィタッカーが
いわゆる思考が貪瞋痴に関わる思考であることと
それがもう不善であると
悪であるということと
またそうするとこれを置き換えて
善たる思考に置き換え
置き換えなさい 置き換えたところで心が統一して
修行うまく進んでサマーディも生まれるんだぞという
そのポイントを繰り返して繰り返して繰り返して言うんです
まあたとえは別にもう大した難しいことではないんだけど
木 木 細工の場合は あの釘は同じ木で作るんですよ
まあ鉄の釘ではなくて
で それを外したい場合はどうすればいいかというと
やっぱりこの透けている釘が粗っぽく大きいんで
それを細い木の釘を持ってそれを叩けば
あの釘はポソンと落ちちゃうんですね
するとこの釘が なくなっちゃうんですね
それはごく普通の木工細工の場合はもう誰でもやってることなんです
ですから 荒っぽいごつい思考をもっともっと細い
もっと鋭い思考で抜けてもらうという
まあそれはケースの一
で 次にケース二なんですね Tassa
ce bhikkhave bhikkhuno dhamma nimitta anya nimittam manasikaro
to kusalo pasanghitam
uppajjanti eva papaka kusala vitakka chando pasanghit
a pidoso pasanghita pimoho
pasanghita pi tena bhikkhave bhikkhu na tesam vitakkana
adhinavo upaparikhitabbo
ケース二になっちゃうんですね Tassa
まあその時比丘のその比丘たちにdhamma nimitta anya nimittam manasikarotoその変えた思考の対象から違う思考対象に置き換え
るでしょ
その置き換えてそのものを強引に思考しても
だから修行者が修行中で何か頭に雑念が生まれてくる
その雑念がずっと回転する
それは見てみると貪瞋痴に関わる思考なんですね
で これはいけないと思って
わざと強引に違う対象を思考しようとする
違うことを考えようではないかといって
この考え方を変えてみる
変えてみてもuppajjanti eva papaka kusalaダンマ
変えてみたことは変えてはみたんだけど
それでも生まれてくるんですね
不善たる思考が悪の思考がそれでも生まれてくる場合はね
だから一番目のケースで直ったら
それでサマーディが生まれるでしょう
それでケースクローズなんですね
でも 置き換えてみてもうまくいかない場合はどうしますかと
置き換えてみてもうまくいかない
それでも欲の思考がどんどん湧いてくると
そのときどうすればいいかと
それは番目のケースなんですね Tena
bhikkhave bhikkhu na tesam vitakkana adhinavo upaparikhitabboその時その比丘がtesam
vitakka
その妄想のその思考のadhinava欠点というかね
危険であることをというか
この危険な特色ですね
いわゆる悪いところ どんなものにもいいところ悪いところがあるんですよ
だから物を観察するときは
まあまあ 仏教の世界ではこの一概にあ
これがいい これが悪いというふうに判断はしません
どんなものにしたってもadhinavaがありますとanisansaがあります
どんなものにも adhinava
というのは悪い結果を出す特色anisansaっていうのは良い結果を出す特色
どんなものにもあります
じゃあゴミって悪いですかと
それは一概に言えませんよ
ゴミにも悪い結果を出す特色もありまして
良い結果を出す特色もあります
だから どんなものについてでも
仏教の知ってる人々はそんなに真剣にこれがいい
これが悪いというふうに飛びかかることっていうのはしない
お金がよろしいですか？で
全然 あ そうですよ もう何よりお金はそういうふうに言わないんですね
命よりもお金だよというふうに
普通の世界ではそう思ってはいるんだけど
仏教ではそうじゃないんですね
お金にしたってもadhinavaがありまして anisansa
があると adhinava
っていうのはこのディメリットであって anisansa
ってのはメリットなんですね
だからどんなものにはメリットとデメリットがあるんで
それ両方見てほしいと
でなきゃ大変なことになるんだと
だから いろんなことに飛び込むっていうことは
思考としてでも感情としてでも
どうしてもいけない もっと冷静でクールにいるのは仏教の世界なんですね
すごい素晴らしいと思うものを持ってね
これはどうですかと言って
もう飛び上がって感動するってことはほとんどないんです
まあいいところはあるんだけど
同時にいろいろディメリットのところもあるんじゃないかと
両方見る で それだけじゃないんです
仏教の観察はもう一つnissaranaというものをしなくちゃいけないんですね
だからその何かものがある
それはあったものについて
人間にはメリット見えるかディメリット見えるか
それ二つしかない いわゆる片目しか見ない
メリット見えるものについては
ものすごい欲を出して
欲しい欲しいと欲の感情で苦しんじゃうんですね
あ これが悪いとディメリットだけ見ちゃうと
もう嫌な感情で 嫌だ 捨てましょう
壊しましょうというふうなことで
破壊的になって もうすごい怒りで苦しんじゃうんですね
だから 俗世間では お金にしても
仕事にしても 世界にしても
社会にしても どんな対象でもよろしいんですけど
どんなものにしたっても
欲で苦しむか 怒りで苦しむかっていう結果しか出てこない
仏教の世界ではどんなものもメリット
デメリット両方を持っていますよと
思う時は怒りも欲も生まれてこないんですね
まあ悟ってない場合は生まれてくるかもしれませんだけど
しがみつくということはないんですね
だから欲が生まれてきたっても
悪いところ見えると欲が減る
減っちゃいますから すごく薄くなっちゃうんですね
あるものを見てすごい怒りが生まれても
やっぱりメリットの方を見ると
その怒りがすごく薄くなって
人を苦しめる 悩めるどころまでは進まないんですね
ですから そういう風な観察能力さえ持っていけば
かなり人間にこの世の中で楽に何も問題を起こさずにいることはできるんですね
それでこれ アーディーナとアーニサンサを見る時はそういうことなんです
もう一つ ニッサラナというものを見なくてはいかん
ニッサラナっていうのは
そういうものから関係ない場合はどうですかと
関係ないこと いわゆる離れること
捨てることも考えちゃうんですね
この3番目はヴィラッスに心は傾いてくれるんですね
例えばお金はどうでしょうかと
ある人が命よりお金が大事ですよと言うかもしれません
ある人はとんでもないお金のおかげで人を殺したりもするんではないかとか
とんでもない悪人やと
悪の塊やと 財産はと言うかもしれません
だからお金は悪の塊やという人が怒りで苦しんじゃう
命より大事やと思う人がそれで欲で苦しんでしまっちゃう
まあいいところもあって悪いところがあるんだなと思った人が
まあそんなに苦しむということはないんですね
自分に見える範囲で まあ欲が薄くなっちゃうんですね
明確に見えるんだったら
もうプラスマイナスでゼロになっちゃいますけど
怒りも欲も生まれてこない
でももう一つ考えてみると
じゃあお金に関わりないということはどういうものか
お金から離れたらどうです
そうするとアーディーナの問題もないし
アーニサンサの問題もないんではないかと
いわゆる欲も関係もないし
怒りも関係なくなるんではないかというふうに
この離れることも考えてみるんですね
まあ全くなかったらどうですかと
だから子供がいることはどういうことかというと
それは素晴らしいという人もいて
ものすごい面倒くさいという人がいて
どちらでもまあ正しくないんですね
だから子供がいることでいいところもあって
悪いところもある 幸福もあって不幸もあると
じゃあ子供に依存することから離れてみたらどうですかと
そういうものがない状態だったらどうでしょうかと
だから いわゆるそういうものは必要としない状態っていうのは
またすごい違う心の次元なんですね
ただ関係ない 関係ないと捨てただけで
その違う次元という意味ではなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから お金に子供に財産となどなどに依存しない状態だったらいかがでしょうかっていう
これもっとすごい強い心の状態も考えてみるんですね
ですから 物事を観察するときはアッサダーディー・ニッサラナという
いわゆるアーニサンサとアーディーナ
ニッサラナという 3つの立場で考えるんですよ
で またあります ものを観察する時の立場っていうのはね
その 3つだけでもね まあ覚えておけば役に立つと思いますけど
そこでこのこの場合はこの思考が生まれてきた
思考は置き換えようとしました
置き換えとしてもうまくいかない
それでも貪瞋痴が湧いてくる
その場合はこの強引に勝手に湧いてくるこの妄想思考について
まあもうどうにもならん
もうどんどん湧いてくるんだから
そのものについてアーディーナワを観察する
だからものすごい心理学的なんですよ
だから抑えて抑えて なんとかもう歯を噛んでというそういうことじゃない
もうもうどうにもならん
自分で頑張ってみたんだけど
違うものを考えようではないかと
でもうまくいかない あまりにも感情が激しくて
もう湧いてくる その場合は
その思考自体を対象にして
そのもののアーディーナワを考えてみるんですね
アーディーナワというのはディメリットの方を考えてみるんですね
一生懸命 どのようにかというと
イティピ イミー ヴィタッカ アクセラ
イティピ イティピっていうのはこの考え方なんですね
こういう風に こういう風に考えるとっていう意味なんですね
イミー ヴィタッカ アクセラ
この妄想思考がアクセラであると
こういう風に考えちゃうと
私はこういうことをするんではないかと
そんなことしたらもう不善でしょうにと
こんな考え方で 私はまたまたこういうこういう風になってしまうんではないかとかね
思考を使うんですよ 例えば修行中はね
家に帰りたいなとか思ってしまったら
それは欲でしょうに あ
もう家に帰るんじゃなくて修行するんだぞといて
修行のことをやれといくら考えてやっぱり家がまたまた割り込んでくる
まあしょうがない その場合
じゃあ家に帰ったらどうなるんですかね
じゃあ修行をやめることになるでしょうに
家に行ったらあれやらなくちゃいけない
これやらなくちゃいけないとか
そうすると まあまあ子供たちに会ったり
いろんなことで またまた自分がもうどんどんどんどんどんどんそこに落ちるんではないかとかね
それも悪いでしょうと
私は戒律も破らなくちゃいかんでしょうとかね
修行をやめなくちゃいかんでしょうとかね
そういう風に このその対象を否定しないで
その対象を実行すればどのようになるものかと
どんどんアーディーナワだけ考える
イティピ イミー ヴィタッカ サワッジャ
イティピ こういう風に考えると
このヴィタッカが この妄想思考がサワッジャ
サワッジャっていうのはこの悪という意味ですよ
ワッジャっていうのは間違っているというね
サワッジャ 間違っているんだよと
いわゆる悪ですよと イティピ イミー ヴィタッカ ドゥッカ ヴィパーカー
このように考えると この思考がドゥッカ ヴィパーカー
苦しみを作ってくるんだと
タッサ
テサン ヴィタッカーナン アーディーナワン ウパパリッカートー ヘー パーパカー クサラ ヴィタッカー チャン
ドーパサンヒターピ ドーソーパサンヒターピ モーホーパサンヒターピー テー パヒーヤンティ テー アッバッタン ガッチャンティ
このように これが危険だ
これが危険だと考えちゃうと
やっぱり消えていくんだよと
タッサ パハナ アッチャッタン エーヴァ チッタン サンティッペティ
それで心の中にあの対象
ここ自分の内に 瞑想の中に心が安定して確定して
エーコー ディホーティ
統一してサマーディが生まれてくる
それまた例えが出てくるんですね
セイヤターピ ビッカラ エー イッティーワ プリソーワ ダハロー ユワ マンダナ ジャーティコー アヒ クナテーナ
クックラ クナテーナワ マヌッサ クナテーナワ カンテーア サッテーナ アッティーエッヤ ハラーイエッヤ ディドッチェ
ッヤ エヤメーワコー ビッカラエータッサチェ ビッコーノー タンマ ニミッターと読むと
アニャン ニミッタ マニッカルオーとつなげるんですね
で 例えばこの 例えばで明確にしてあげるんですね
セイヤターピ ビッカラ エー イッティーワ プリソーワ
女の人か男の人はか ダハロー
まあ若い ダハローっていうのは
まだすごい年下っていうことで
子供っていう意味使ってますけど
ユワっていうのは若いっていうことで
いわゆる若者の女の子が男の子がっていうことで
マンダナ ジャーティコー
かなりおしゃれ まあおしゃれ好きなのはやっぱりこの若い時なんですね
だからもうかなりおしゃれに凝っている男の子か女の子かがいて
その子をアヒ クナテーナ
クナタっていうのは死体ということで
まあ腐っているという意味もありますけどね
汚い この腐っている このアヒ
ヘビを クックラ クックラというのは犬
犬の死体 マヌッサクナという
あるいは人の死体で カンテーアーサっていうのを首につけてあげる
この若者の随分おしゃれが好きでも
いつでも体洗って丁寧に整理して
お化粧して もうもう何だかんだもう
もうかなり磨いている年頃でしょうし
その時は誰かがこの腐っている蛇を首にかけたり
あるいは首にももう死んでいるもう犬をね
つけてあげたり あるいは人間の遺体でもいいんですけど
まあこれはまあ持ち運びなさいと
そのままで 言うとどうなるんでしょうか？アッティーエイエハラーエイエ
もう我慢できないでしょうに
ものすごく嫌になるんですね
アッティーエティハラエティジーグッチェティという
いつでもその 3つの言葉はセットなんです
アッティーエティハラエティジーグッチェティ
こちらはこのオプティティブケースでアッキーエイエハラーエイエジグッチェイエというこの格変化というか
動詞の変化がしていますけどね
オプティティブというケースで
この単数ですね  3人称の
いわゆる このオプティティブケースというのは
このこの可能性を語るときはね
嫌がるだろうという意味で
アッティーエティハラエティジーグッチェティすごい強烈な
ものすごく汚いと 嫌やというふうに思うんでしょうね
もう体が震えるほど気持ち悪くなるという
だから若い子にそんなことさせちゃうと
どれほど汚いと思うでしょうかっていうことなんですね
嫌がるでしょうということ
エイアメーワコービッケータッサテービッキュノータンマーニミッターアンニャンニミッタマニシカロートと音訓なんですけど
それでそのビクにもそのニミッタを変えてみても
欲が生まれてくる場合は欲のデメリットを観察する
こういう風になったら大変でしょう
こういう風になるでしょう
こういう風になるでしょうとかね
デメリットを考えて考えてみると
ものすごく嫌になってくるんだと
でもまあそれは機能するのはやっぱりこの本気になって修行して
何かこの清い優れた清い心を作りたいと
俗世間はもうもうもうこりごり
嫌やと言って出家した人の場合なんですけど
だからこの中途半端な思考の人に
どうしてももうどうにもならん
このまあ神能ない人にとっては
まあそういう心理学的な指導っていうのは効かない可能性ありますよ
だから人格はしっかりしてほしいっていうことは
いつでも当たり前でありますから
だから家に帰りたくなったところで
家に帰ったら大変でしょうと
仕事をしなくちゃあかんでしょうとか
奥さんにもいろいろ言われるでしょうとか
でもまあ まあそれぐらいはどうったことないと思うかもしれませんしね
でもそれは捨ててきた人にとっては
なんでまた同じ泥沼の
落ちなくちゃいけないんで
せっかく上がってるんだからといって
また怖くなって嫌になって
いわゆる出家した時の自分の思考ですね
それをまた蘇ってくるんですよ
ですからまあ根性が弱い人にはあまり効くということはないんでしょうと思いますけど
だから たとえ根性が強くて出家するんだと
世俗 俗世間を捨てるんだと
捨てて出家したんだったら
もうどれだけ意味がないんだか
じゃあちょいと中途半端に頑張ってみる
そうと頑張ってる途中で欲の思考が湧いてくるということで
まあそこは自然法則で湧いてくる
その場合はそうやってデメリットを考えて考えてみると
自分がなんで出家したんだろうかということがね
まあ蘇ってきて すごく怖くなって
嫌になって なんて汚い思考でしょうかと
という風に もう自分が汚れだと
体がもう汚いんだと 醜いんだと自分のことを思っちゃうと
その思考が消えていくんです
これはケース２ 次にケース３ Tassate
bikkhave bhikkhuno te sambhavitakkānaṃ adhinavaṃ upapari
kkhato uppajjanti eva
pāpaka akusala vitak
kā. Chando pasanghitāpi, doso pasanghitāpi, moho pasanghitāpi.
Tena bikkhave bhikkhuna te sambhavitakkānaṃ asati amanas
ikāro vā pajjitabbo.
で 三番目 それで 二番目
頑張ってみた デメリットばっかり考えてみた
汚い 醜いやと自分が こんな思考している自分が
もう若者の体にヘビの死骸をつけたような感じになっちゃって
もうもう吐きそうぐらいに
それぐらい気持ち悪いと思ったって
それでも生まれてくる場合はと
だからケース２で頑張ってみても
生まれてくる場合はどうしますかと
その悪い思考が 貪瞋痴の思考が tesaṃ
vitakkānaṃ asati amanasikāro vā pajjitabbo. アサティっていうのはサティの反対
マナシカーラっていうのは考えるということのことですから
アマニシカーラっていうのは考えないことにする
サティを入れないことにする
その思考 いわゆるもうなかったことにすることなんですね
そんなもの出たって出たって全然もう気にしない
それに引っかからないようにして
もうサティ入れない 自分の修行の方向へ
まあその思考を放っておいて
修行の方へ心を持っていくということなんです
その時は必ずその思考が消えてしまうと
だから番目は弱いんです
だから番目はこの思考するんですよ
だからとさんはなんか似ているんではないかなと思えるかもしれませんが
似てはないと思いますけど
一番目はこの置き換える
やっぱり妄想しちゃうんですね
だからこの何か頭に浮かんだら
それは悪い思考だから
まあ違うことをわざと強引に考えるではないかとしてしまうんですね
で それでうまくいかない
それでこんなこと考えちゃったら汚い
醜いやと思ってみる その時でも思考に引っかかってるんですね
で 三番目はもう関わりをしないことにする
関わりをしないことにして
アサティ・アマニシカーラっていうのはもう関係ない
なかったことにして 自分の修行はそれでも続けてみるということ
もう勝手に思考がもう勝手にやってくださいと
自分が修行を進んでいくんだと
そちらにこのいわゆる燃料をあげないことにしますね
このサティっていうのは燃料になりますからね
考える時はね それでそれ消えてしまいますよと
例えば
Seyyathāpi bikkhave cakkhumā puriso vāpātagataṃ rūpānaṃ adassanakāmo hassa
so nimīleyya vā aññena vā aparokkeyya evaṃ evako bhikkhu. Bhikkhave tassate
bikkhuno te sambhavitakkānaṃという風につなげる
だから実際にこの経典
フルバージョンで言おうとすると
これまあページぐらい続けちゃいます
かなり長いんですよ だから同じことをものすごい回
回 回繰り返していくんで
ポイントをね 絶対忘れられないようにということで
だからこちらは印刷する過程で全部省略しています
例えばこのチャックマーポリスをよく目が見える人がアーパーツガターナンルーパーナン
自分の目に入ったルーパに過ぎて
いろんなものを目に入っちゃいます
アーパーツガタっていうのは視野に入ったもの
目がある人の視野に何か入りました
見るもの 入ったんだけど
アダッサナカーモ・ヴァッサ
見たくはない 目に入った
視野に入ったものは 見たくはない場合はどうすればいいんですかね
そう 見ないで目を閉じればいいでしょうに
見たくなかったら 見えませんから
あるいはアンーネーナ・ヴァーアポローキャ
あるいは他のところを見れば？こちらに何か目に入るから見たくないんだったら他の方を見れば？それで済みますからね
そういう風な感じで 何か思考に入ったらそれにサティをしないで他のものにサティを
修行にサティを持っていけばそれだけのことやと
そこでケース四になりますね
タッ
サ・テー・ビッカラ・エー・ビッキュノー・テー・サンペ・ウィタッカーナン・アサティ・アマニシカーラン・アパッジャヤトー・ウパッジャンティ・ヨー・パータカ・アプサラ・ウィタッカ
それでアサティ サティ入れないこと
考えないことにしても
それでもこの不善たる思考が湧いてくる場合はどうしますかと
で これで経典のタイトルになっている言葉が出てくるんですね
テーサン・ウィタッカーナン・ウィタッカ・サンカーラ・サンターナン・マニシカータッタ
そのウィタッカの ウィタッカっていうのは思考
妄想ですね ウィタッ ウィタッカ・サンカーラ・サンターナという
その場合はサンターナ・サンターナですね
サンターナとも言いますけどね
まあ注釈書で随分明確にこの思考を管理する方法を書いてはありますけど
いろいろありそうでやらね
そこでこのケース三でしたっけ？四
四番目はウィタッカ・サンカーラ・サンターナンという言葉なんですけど
まあこれはなかなかこの注釈書でいろいろいろいろ説明しますが
かなり長い説明ありますけど
まあ経典ではあまり説明されていないんだから
随分簡単な言葉ではないかなと思います
ウィタッカっていうのは思考
サンカーラっていうのは
まあサンカーラですから
この思考を生み出すこのエネルギーのことなんですね
いわゆるこのどうにも我慢ならない
もう思考が湧いてくる
だから思考を生み出すこのエネルギーのことはサンカーラというんですね
ウィタッカ・サンカーラ
だからこの心の中で何かがエネルギーが出てきちゃって
それでぼんぼん思考を作り出すんですね
だからそれを抑えをさせてっても
このエネルギーがあるんだったらね
やっぱり生まれてくるんですね
ですから このウィタッカ・サンカーラ・サンターナン
で サンターナンという意味なんですね
これでも いわゆるこの因果法則に戻るっていうことなんですけど
注釈書でも言っているのは
まあなんで私はこういうことを考えているんでしょうかと
で なんでこういう思考が湧いてくるんでしょうかと
いて この因果法則考えてみるんですね
原因を探してみるんですね
例えば家に帰りたくなったと
男の人がもう出家して修行する
突然家を思い出してしまって
もう奥さんと子供のことを思い出しちゃって
どうにもならんことになってしまったと
その場合はこのいろいろやってみたんだけど
3つもうまくいかなかって
このケース4になってしまって
ヴィタッカサンターラにするんですね
ヴィタッカサンターラというのは家に帰りたくなりましたと
家族に会いたくなりましたと
なんででしょうかと それ調べてみれば
もういとも簡単に見つかるんです
それはもしかすると蚊に刺されたぐらいのことかもしれませんよ
調べてみれば 修行中も蚊に刺された
痒くなったと その瞬間で
まあ普通だったら これはもう叩いて
もうもう殺すでしょうとかね
まあ噛むでしょうとか思うでしょうにね
すぐに次にだったら まあ自分のことだけじゃなくて
子供の蚊に刺されちゃうと
自分が子供の体をポチンポチンとぶって
もう蚊を殺しちゃったでしょうとかね
子供が痒い痒いと言って
自分が一生懸命かいてあげたのではないかとかね
この思考というのはすっごい早いんだからね
蚊に刺された瞬間で まあ自分が子供の背中なんかかいてあげたこととかね
すぐ思い出しちゃう その瞬間にもう家族になってきて
奥さんも出てきて もうみんな仲々ワイワイと生活したことがもうボンボンボンボン出てきて
それで他のことを思考しようと思っても無理だったら
そうやってこの なんでこのエネルギーが湧いてくるんでしょうかと
きちんと順番で考えてみると
ただの蚊に刺されたことでもう減速して帰りたくなってるんではないかという
このシステムが見えてくるんです
ほんのそれぐらいつまらないことから
もう思考が 妄想がもう発展するんですよ
だから本人がわからない
後でそのこの嫌になって家に帰りたくなって
1日頑張って修行してうまくいかない
またどんどんこの嫌な気持ちが成長するでしょうに
それでもう出家もやめて家に帰ってしまう可能性もあるでしょうに
でも その本人がなんで家に帰ったかと
この順番できちんと考えてみると
修行中蚊に刺されたことだと
それと結果と原因を調べてみると
あまりにもバカバカらしくなってくるんですね
蚊に刺されたんだから減速したんだぞと
これ人に言えるもんじゃないでしょうに
それは だからどんな思考でも
そういう単純なつまらないことから生まれるんです
生まれて管理できないほど大げさになるんです
それは思考のパターンなんですね
ですから この整理してみなさいと
思考を それは 4番目のケースなんですね
お釈迦様の例えはこういう例えで
セイヤーターピ・ビックウィ・プリソ・シーガン・ガッチャイ
ある人がものすごい速く歩いている
シーガン・ガッチャイ
とにかく急いでもう早く早く歩いていく
それで考えてみる タッセ・エラン・アッサ
そのように考えてみる
キンヌ・コーハン・シーガン・ガッチャ・ネ
なんで私はそんなに勢いで速く歩いてるんでしょうかと
別に考えてみたらどうってことないのではないかと
そんなに急がなくても
そう思っちゃうと ヤンノー・ナーハン・サニカン・ガッチャイ・ヤ
ゆっくり行きましょうと
ゆっくり行くようになるんだと
それでゆっくり歩いていくと
キンヌ・コーハン・サニカン・ガッチャイ・ネ
なんで私はゆっくりゆっくり歩いているんでしょうかと
それで考えたら 別に用事もあるわけじゃないし
別にどうってことないし
こんなことやっていいんじゃないかなと
思ったら じゃあ止まった方がいいんじゃない？それで止まると
それで止まって立ってるんですね
そこで なんで私は立ってるんですか？別に何か立ってる用事でもありますかと
いや だって別に立っている必要性もあるわけじゃないんで
だったら座ればいいんじゃないかと
それで座るんですね 座っていいって真面目に座っていると
なんで私はそんなに座っているんかね
用事でもありますかと
別にどうってことない
だったら横になるんだぞと
で もっと横になって楽になると
だからすっごい速く歩いた人が
もう横になって寝ているという結果になるんですね
だから そういう風に なんでこれをやってるんでしょうかと考えてみなさいと
だから これ その質問 普通の人に出してみたってもね
よく人が落ち着きがなくて
神経質でいろんな なんであんたそんなに落ち着きがないんでしょうかとかね
聞いてみてください 調べちゃうと
何の原因出てこないでしょう
それで 言った人も言われた人もアホらしくなっちゃって
その神経質なくなるでしょうに
例えばそういうもの 必死で歩いていると
なぜそんなに必死でしょうかと
まあ用事がある場合はそれはしょうがないんだけど
そう用もない時はもうアホらしさに気づくんですよ
この場合のこの妄想っていうのは用がないでしょうに
修行中だから だから用がないんだから
必ずこのなんでやと考えちゃうと消えるはずなんです
例えば この例えば何か明日か明後日か
例えばもうティッシュ必要になるんだよと
今 4つぐらいあるんだけど
まあそろそろ切れるんだから買いましょうと言ったところで
一人の人が必死になって走るんだと店までティッシュ買おうと
その走っている場合は
なんでそんなに必死になって走るんでしょう？と言ったら
ティッシュ買うんです
それ走る必要あるんでしょうかと
だって もう 2 日間ぐらいでもなくたっても大丈夫でしょうしね
だったらゆっくり行けばいいんじゃないかと
ゆっくり行ったっても
私はなんでゆっくりティッシュを買うために
必ずしも今日買う必要があるかというと
いいえ 今日は私は別な勉強に来たんだから
それをやめてティッシュを買う
バカバカらしい 明日買っちゃえばいいでしょ
明日何も用事もないんだからといって戻ることさえもできるでしょうに
じゃあ明日にしますと
だからこのただ単にやっていることっていうのは
ものすごいたくさんあるんですよ
本当に用事があってやる場合は
人間に苦しみも悩みも何もあるわけじゃないんですよ
喉が渇いたら水を飲むとかね
みんなご飯食べたいと言ったところで
自分が料理できるんで
じゃあ作りましょうとかね
それぐらいは人間だって苦しいでも何でもないんです
用事があって それはしていると
では 人間がかなり苦しんでバカなことをやっているのは
ほとんど用事がない場合なんです
用事がないんだけど やる
掃除する必要はないんだけど
もう決まっている時間で厳密に掃除をする
それでストレス溜まっちゃうんですね
いろいろ決まりをつけちゃって
スケジュールをつけちゃって
それに自分をはめてもらって
もうもう必死に苦労しながら生きているというふうな
本当にそこまでやる必要があるんでしょうか？とちょっと考えてみれば
もうかなりリラックスできるんでしょうしね
そういうことで この場合は修行真っ最中でしょうし
余計なことを考える必要はないでしょうし
なんでこんなことを考えているんでしょうか？と
ちゃんと人間で考えてみると
何か用事でもありますか？何か必要なことでしょうか？とかね
なんでそういうふうなことを思ってしまったんでしょうか？とかね
で 見てみれば いかにバカバカらしいかということに気づいて
すぐ消えてしまうんですね
まあ時々耳にちょっとした時計の音が入っただけでも
それにサティ入れなかっただけで妄想が回転し始めて
どこで終わるかわからないんですよ
その妄想が そこで時計を恨んで
周りの人々のことを恨んで
瞑想を教える人のことまで恨んで
仏教そのものまで恨んで
次に宗教全体的にも恨んで
それから反宗教的になって
どこまで行くかわからないんですね
修行のところじゃなくなっちゃう
だから順番で考えてみれば
ただの時計の音で はないかということを見つかるんですよ
だからそれこの時計の音で私は今反宗教主義者になりましたよという
だから世の中でこの殺戮やらね
大量殺人やら戦争やら
そういうどんなものでも
すごいつまらない単純なことから思考から生まれるもんなんですよ
元をたどってみればどうったことないとんでもない単純なことなんです
でも思考の管理がないんだから
この世の中はまあこんな様なんですね
だから瞬時に膨張してしまう
この核兵器と同じなんですよ
原発とかなんかほんのちょっと事故を起こしちゃうと
どんどんみるみるうちにそれを広げていって
もう大惨事になってしまう
もうもう手に施しよう全くない状態にまでなってしまっちゃうでしょうね
そんな感じ それよりひどいんですよ
思考は 原発とかなんとかにしたっても
まあそれはわかっているもので測れるんですよ
どれぐらい危険かっていうことはね
この原発はこれぐらいウランやらいろんな燃料を持ってるんだから
これはこれぐらいエネルギー持ってますよと
これは事故を起こしちゃったら
これぐらいの範囲で これぐらいの年代まで危険ですよっていうことは計算できます
思考にはそれもできません
もっとひどいんですね
パッと広げて もうもう二
三秒でもいないででもどうなるかわからなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この何か思考が来て
こうやって人を苦しませた場合は
もうヴィタッカサンカーラサンターナということをしてしまうんですね
整理してみるということをしてみるのです
では この思考を整理してみようではないかと
これはどういうことで生まれたんでしょうかというふうに
順番で遡ってみればいいのです
そこでケース五かな それで五番目のケース
そうやって まあただ蚊に刺されただけで原則して家に帰りたくなったんだっていうかね
そういうふうに思ってみても
それでも思考が湧いてくる可能性はあります
それはケース五ですね
Vitakkasantāna
m manasikārotuppajjam piho pātakakusalā vitakkā chandūpasanghitampi
dosūpasanghitam mohūpasanghitampi tena bhikkhave bhik
khunā dantehi dantamādhāya
jīvhāyatāluṁāhaccha cetasā cittaṁ abhiniggaṁhitabbaṁ abhinippīlet
abbaṁ abhisantāpetabbaṁ.
その時はものすごい激しいことを教えているんですね tena
bhikkhave bhikkhunāそれだったらその比丘がdantehi dantamādhāya dantehi
というのは歯でdantam歯をādhāya
捕まってという いわゆる歯を噛んでという意味なんですね
ぎっしりと歯を噛んで jīvhāyatāluṁāhaccha
jīvhāというのは舌でtāluṁというのは上のところ
上顎 舌で上顎をぎゅっと締め付けて
いわゆる我々何かきつそうことをやると
どうしても歯を噛むでしょう
重いものを運ぶ時やらね
ものすごい痛い もうもう何かにぶつけてものすごい痛くなったら
じっと歯を噛んでこらえるでしょうね
そんなことなんですね
もう 歯を噛んで舌を噛んで
もう頑張りなさいと chetasā
自分の思考でcittaṁ abhiniggaṁhitabbaṁ
自分の心で心を徹底的にいじめてみなさいと
いわゆる非難することniggahatiっていうのはもう脅すことなんですね
徹底的に自分の思考をもう脅して非難してみる abhinippīletabbaṁ
というのはいじめなさいということですね
自分の思考をね 徹底的にもう非難していじめて abhisantāpetabbaṁ
抑えて管理しなさい santāpe
っていうのは管理ですね
徹底的に非難して 侮辱して,もういじめて
この思考を管理する そうすると消えてしまうと
それは番目の最後の手段なんですね Thoeva
seyathāpi bhikkhave balavā puriso dubbalataraṁ purisaṁ
sesevā gahitvā khaṇḍhevā
gahitvā abhiniggaṁhaye abhinippīleya abhisantāpeya evaṁ
evako bhikkhave tassuti
bhikkhuno tesantu vitakkānaṁ.それで凄い凶暴な力強い人がすごい弱い人を捕まって
その人をいじめたり脅したりしたら
その人の管理できるでしょうと
そのようなものだと  その例え
例えば暴力団がみんな怖いでしょうね
暴力団が何か言ったら真剣真面目にやるでしょうね
そんなので暴力団にもういじめられると
建物を壊しちゃうと困りますからね
これこれやれと言ったら
はいはいわかりましたと
もうやってあげる で なんで人間が泥棒しないで
人を殺さないで 随分おとなしくいるんでしょうかね
できてんだから みんな性格とんでもないことでしょうに
全く出来が悪いんです
でも警察 法律があるんだから
警察 法律というのは徹底した暴力手段でしょうに
それは怖い もう誰にも
もうヤクザにしたっても
法律 警察の場合はもうどうにもことどうすることもできませんだからね
だから徹底的な暴力組織があるんだから
どんな人間にも乗り越えられない
政治家にもどうすることもできません
総理大臣にもどうすることもできません
法律と警察っていうのは
そういうことで この世の中っていうのは管理されてますよ
軍隊と警察と法律というもので
それなくなったもう終わりでしょうに
みんなお互いにやりたい放題
これさえやってしまいます
人間ができてるわけじゃないんです
だからできてない 悪いことをする
するんだから軍隊は必要になっちゃうし
警察も法律も必要になっちゃうし
刑務所も処刑も何から何まで必要になって
それがもう明らかに暴力なんですよ
でもその暴力のおかげで
みんな平和で互いに迷惑をかけないで生きているんですね
だから  5番目のこの悪い不善たる思考
不善たる妄想を抑えるために
もう最後の手段 まあ暴力なんですね
この暴力も仏教的な暴力だから
自分で自分の舌を噛んで歯を噛んで
徹底的にその思考をね
もう二度とこんなことを考えませんと
もうどんな方法でもいいんで
逆立ちしたってもよろしいし
海に飛び込んだってもよろしいし
もうもう何とかでもして
その思考をやめなくちゃいけないんですね
足にロープでもつけて崖にぶら下がっていたってもよろしいし
まあそういうとにかくもう暴力的な手段でやりだってみてくださいと
まあそれで終わりますね
行は あの このあの原因探しなさいというところには
こちらのイソップに入っているこのあるジャータカ物語が引用していますけど
すごい単純なストーリーで
あるウサギがね グーグーと昼寝しているんですね
昼寝していると なんでありがたいですかと
この大地の上で私はもう寝ているんだからと
あら ちょっと待ってください
この大地がもうもう転がっちゃったらどうしますかと
自分が倒れて大変なことになるんではないかと
もう何か考えちゃうんで
それで怖くなっちゃうんですね
その時はこのそちらへんで
もう木の下で大体寝るとかね
この木の実は一つポツンと落ちたんですね
枯れた葉っぱの上に 落ちたところで音が出て
葉っぱがサラサラサラと音を立てちゃったんですね
このウサギがね 大地が転がっちゃったらどうしようか
大変だな 危険だなと どうみんな大変なことになるではないか
そこばっかり考えてる途中でいきなり音が出て
[背景音楽]で 飛び上がっちゃったんですね
怖くなっちゃって 飛び上がった瞬間でもうどうにもわからなくなっちゃって
今あの 大地が転がったらどうしようかって
どうもくだらんことを考えてでしょうね
その瞬間で怖くなって飛び上がっちゃったでしょうね
それで考え方ジャブっちゃったんですね
やっぱり大地が転がってくるんだよと
昔は平らだからね 平らでなきゃそれは意味がないんですよ
大地がこうやってもう転がってくる
そこで逃げよ逃げよと言って一生懸命逃げるんですね
で 逃げると もうそこら辺の他のウサギたちが
あんたなんで逃げるん？大地が転がってくるんだよと
早く逃げると 君たちもウサギたちも逃げる
みんな群れで それで他の大きな動物たちもあの話聞いて
もう鹿やらイノシシたちやらね
みんなもう走る ものすごい
もう森の中の動物全部
だから大勢の走ると 他の動物
なんでか大地が転がって
まあそうですかと じゃあ逃げようと
どうせどんどんこの言葉がもうもう実力持ってるんですね
事実やと だって全ての鹿たちやら
全ての鳥たちやら もうイノシシたちやら鹿たちやら
もうみんなもう何千匹も行っちゃうと
他のもっと大きい動物たちもそれを聞いたりする
それでまあもう牛たちやら
もうみんな馬たちやら
みんな走っていて そこで走るとこのライオンのところにももう通っていくと
ライオンももう昼寝してるんだから
もうみんな走っていくと
なんで君たちが走るんだい？大地が転がってくるんだと
それでライオンとサビルのそれぐらいの大きな凶暴な動物たちだからね
虎とかね それで君ら誰に聞いたんですか？と言うと
自分の次のこちらから聞いたんだよと
で 君ら誰から聞いたんですか？と
こうやって調べるんです
じゃあ君らは誰から聞いたんですかと
で どんどんどんどん いや
見たんでしょうか？と聞くんですね
いえ 見てない この人々が言ってるんだから
じゃあ君ら見たの？いえ
見てないんだけど この人々が言うんだからという風に
どんどんどんどんウサギの群れに行って
ウサギの群れ 君ら見たんでしょうかね？大地が転がる
え？見たじゃなくて この誰でしたっけ？これを私はこの人から
私はこの人から聞いてって
最後にこの人から聞いたんだよと
この行った最後の一匹のウサギですから
それで君見たんですか？と
いえ 私は見てないんだけどと
私は見てると そういう風な考えだと
突然ポクンと音が出ていて
それでもう出てきて逃げてきたんだ
だからまあ転がってくるんではないかと
じゃあ行ってみましょうと
言って このライオンが先に先頭になって元に戻ってみたら
何なんだ この枯れ葉の上にこの木の実はこれで相当あって
それで終わるんですね
あの騒ぎは だからそのエピソードはいろんなものに使うエピソードなんですけど
このニュースっていうのはどういうものかっていうよね
ほとんど嘘しか世の中で広げないしね
だから原因見てみれば何のこともないんですからね
だからこのあまりこのね
まあいわゆるこの調べてないところっていうのは
まるっきり気にしないというね
というのはね 仏教の立場なんですね
ニュースで何が流れたってもね
全然気にしない 言ってる通りに
まあそうですねと言って大騒ぎしたりとかね
そういうのは無知なやり方でね
そのために使いますけど
やっぱりあの恐怖感とあの驚きとあの大騒ぎっていうのは
原因見たらば 何よこれっていうことで
あまりにもバカバカしくなって瞬時に消えるでしょうね
ですから ヴィパッサナーサンカーラサンターナという思考の
なんで思考が生まれたと
どういうわけで生まれたんでしょうかと探してみなさいよと
あの暴力手段は番目ですけど
それは番目の説明で あの暴力手段はそんなに難しくはないんですからね
で 出家の人々は昔はこのそうやってこの欲が生まれてきて
修行に心が集中しないと簡単にやるってばなくてね
どうにもならん時はね
自分で頑張りますよ 自分で頑張ってもいかない場合は
ものすごく恥をかけてもらうんですね
いわゆるみんなに言うふらしちゃうんです
私は本当はこういうことを考えてるんだけど
こういう風に こういう風に人に言えるものじゃないんですよ
言えるものじゃないんだけど
自分がどんな汚い醜い思考をしているんですかと
一緒に修行しているみんなに言っちゃう
言っちゃうと 人の顔を見るとものすごくもうみんなにバレてるんだと
自分で言っちゃったんだから
もう面子が立たないというかね
それでみんなにこの指を指せることできるでしょうに
それでもう精神的に自分で怯えて
もうすぐ消えてしまうんですね
必ずその指導者というか
先生に自分の罪は言います
真面目な修行者はね 言ってしまえば
まあそれだけでなんかものすごいもう
恥ずかしくなってしまって
それっきり消えちゃうんです
その思考 これは一つ この五 bandha の暴力手段ですね
それでもできない場合は
いろいろこのすだ行やら
この難しい厳しい修行なんかはあるのはそのためなんですね
遺体を見るとかね 不浄観をするとかね
死の瞑想をするとか すだ行という 32 がありますからね
そういう厳しい行をやってみたりとか
なんとかして まあこういう激しい暴力手段を使って
まあこの生ぬるいというかね
根性ない自分の性格をしっかり正してもらう
それから修行すると で
最後に全部繰り返し文句で
そういう風にすると心はサマーディになるんだよと
あの思考が消えてしまって
心は内になるんだよと
次の説明するポイントは
なんでこのアッジャッタンサンニシーデティ
心がアッジャッタン 内に確立して安定するんだぞという言葉なんですけどね
それはどういうことでしょうかというと
この妄想というのは外の世界のことなんですね
眼耳鼻舌身の世界なんですね
貪瞋痴の妄想だから だから眼耳鼻舌身にはめられている間では
もう禅定なんかは一つも生まれてこないんですね
だから禅定の世界っていうのは
全く普通の思考とはずいぶん次元が違う
で 禅定がなぜ生まれないかというと
我々はずっと眼耳鼻舌身の情報に依存している
だから欲の思考っていうのは
必ずしも見るものか聞くものか
食べるものか体に触れるものかどちらかなんですね
怒りの思考もそういうものでしょうに
誰か見るものか何かでしょうに
無知の思考もそういうものなんですね
ですから 心が瞑想対象ではなくて
外の世間に行ってるんですね
外へ飛び回ってるんですね
その妄想をカットしたら
外を飛び回ることなく
また瞑想の世界に戻ってくるんだ
で 戻ってきたら外へ出ていかないんだから
眼耳鼻舌身の方にもまた入れませんだから
まあサマーディを作ることができるんです
そこでこの 122 ページの最後
アヤンウッチャティ ビックウェー ビック ウワシ ヴィサッカ パリヤーパテス
アヤンウッチャティ これが言われます
言われるそうと なんですか
ビック ウワシ ヴィタッカ パリヤーヤ パテス
思考の様々な パタっていうのは流れ
道ですね パリヤーヤっていうのは思考が回転する道
いわゆる思考の様々な道がありますね
思考はいろんな方向へ回転してしまっちゃう
だからこのいろんな枝分かれをして思考が回転する
でも個人個人にはもう決まってるんですよ
妄想は よく見てみると
何回何回も10年瞑想したっても
妄想でなかなか 考えてみると毎10年間同じ妄想してるんです
全然すごい複雑で大胆なことをアインシュタイン
みたいな この宇宙の方程式やらなんとか妄想してるわけじゃないんです
全くのくだらない無意味な何かワンパターンのこと
思考 そればっかり 私は十年瞑想している
私は二十年やってるんだ
だからあんたより偉いんだと
結果がない場合はもう同じ妄想の中でずっともうハメられて回転してるんです
だからそこら辺は上手じゃないんだからね
だからこの思考パターンというのはやや複雑ですけど
いろいろ人の合わせてみると複雑ですけど
自分のことだから 自分の妄想はいつでもワンパターンなんです
いつでもワンパターン
同じことを妄想する だから同じことをどこまで妄想するんですかね
それ見たら そんな妄想って同じことではないかとということ見えてくるんですね
だから必要なのはこの思考の道ですね
いわゆるもろもろの妄想の道をね
それを発見して それはワシー管理できる
支配できる ワシーっていうのはこの何でも支配しているっていう意味なんですね
だから この 5つを習った比丘が思考の支配下にあるんですね
妄想を支配できることになっているんです
だから 妄想の管理者と言えるでしょうとお釈迦様は結論出すんですね
妄想の整理できる人 整理整頓できる人やと
いわゆるワシーっていうのはもうプロ
妄想が出たらすぐもう整理しておく
邪魔にならない そういう能力がついてほしいと
これ 5つを習った人がまあ整理整頓のプロであると
で プロだからヤンウィタッカンアーカンキッセティタンウィタッカンウィタッケッセティ
ヤンウィタッカンアーカンキッセティ
何かこの自分が希望する何か思考があるならば
アーカンってのは except ということで
何かこのことは考えたいなと思ったら
タンウィタッカンウィタッケッセティ
その思考をする あ これについて考えてみたいなと思ったら
それについて考えられます
ヤンウィタッカンナアーカンキッセティ
何かの思考をしたくなければ
タンナウィタッカンウィタッケッセティ
それは考えません あ これは考えたくない
だからストップと あ これはちょっと考えた方がいいな
じゃあ考えましょうと
それは考えられる それはすごい能力なんですね
思考したいもののみ思考して
思考したくないものについてはきれいさっぱりストップする
だから今の人々にとっては思考の管理できません
思考が勝手なんですね
思考が勝手に回転する
どうにもならん状態 それは逆にする
私が決めますよと 何を思考して何を思考しないかと
私が決めるんだよという自己管理ができるんですね
で これはこの俗世間の欲世間に当てはめて喋ると
これが勉強の方法なんですよ
なんで人に勉強できないかというと
思考の管理できないんですね
どこかの変なところに行っちゃうんですね
だからこれは考えませんよ
これを考えるぞと というふうに管理できれば
もう勉強の世界でも何でもできるようになるんです
だからブッダがそういうふうにものには仏教は使うなよと
世間のことには絶対使わないと禁止しているんですけどね
でも ものすごい役に立つことは役に立ちます
役に立つどころじゃない
これ抜群のもう桁外れの指導だから
だから人間が勝手に苦しめと
爆弾を落とすんだったら爆弾を落として殺して殺されて
じゃあ苦しめっていうことで放っておくんですね
いくら言ったってもね
理解できませんし 頭がもうひとかけらも智慧がないし
能力はないし 観察っていうことはひとかけらもないし
客観性はないし 主観でわがままで傲慢で見栄で
我こそ正しいやとって思って頑張ってるんだから
まあこれはもう自業自得ですよ
だからもうそういう平和な社会にしたっても
みんな平和と言ったっても
結局感情の奴隷で 感情に言われるままに生きている単なる奴隷で
ただの生き物なんですね
自分の意思で生きているわけじゃないんですね
ですから それは結局いい結果は決して出しません
社会が平和であろうか
戦争であろうか だからこの思考の管理というものは
やってみれば大変いいことで
これは俗世間ではできないな
だって貪瞋痴がいいと思ってるんだから
貪瞋痴に逆らって喋ると随分攻撃してくること
だったらお手上げで ではどうぞ勝手にやってくださいと
なんで金があるんですか？とかね
なんとかそういうふうにかかってくると
どうぞどうぞ 勉強できない
学校に行かないとか何とか言ったっても
これは頓珍のこと で この間なんかとこから電話があったんだけどね
もうだらしないんですね
指導できない 母親から電話があったんだけど
私の話を聞いたらもうだらしなくてね
母親っていうのは いくらかいくらなんでも家族に対してちょっと権力を握って独裁的にやらないとうまく管理できないでしょうに
だからこの まあとにかく少々教えてあげて
これはね とにかくこの単純な本人に
自分の息子に私に電話するように言ってくださいと
電話かけてこなかったんですね
だから登校拒否しているのは子供だから
これは子供の問題なんですね
本当に問題にぶつかっている子供と話してみたいんですよ
それで母が私の教えで
私が子供に教えるという態度でしょうに
いくら私が言ったって理解しますかね
これをまた自分のなりに解釈して
また子供に喋るんだから
決していい国家は出てこない
だから まあ手っ取り早いだから
本人に電話させなさいよと
それはね もう一回また電話が来るんで
私は時間がないんだと
ですから このまた本人に電話させてくださいと
で 断ったんです それぐらい勇気ないんだったらね
まあ諦めた方がいいんです
もう 登校拒否 別に死にませんだから
学校に行かなかったって
だからこれ人格の問題なんですよ
腰抜けでも情けなくても
いつでもいい顔をして見せようではないかと
なんでいい顔を見せるんですかね
結局自分のことしか考えてないでしょうに
旦那にいい顔をして 子供にいい顔をして
自分の立場を安定しようではないかという
汚いんですよ 母親って別にいい顔する必要ないでしょうに
言いたい時は言うと 殴りたい時は殴ると
それぐらいやっぱり家族を管理するのは女だから
どんな社会でも これをわがまま言ったってもどうにもならんでしょうに
それは根性がないと言うんだったらね
もう家族を持つ権利もないんですね
だからアメリカの法律に従って子供は取った方がいいと思いますけども
あんた方にはもう能力はないんだと
権利はないと それぐらい私はきつい決まりはいいと思いますけどね
だからやっぱり結局欲に汚れて学校に行け行けと言ったって
これ欲の世間でしょうに
だけど私はそれを何とか絶たせてほしい
逆なことを言いたかったんですよ
子供に あのね 学校に行っても行かなくてもどうでもいいやと
そんなことはと私はそういうふうに言うんですよ
でも君が腰抜けで怖くて行かなければ
これはかっこ悪いんだよと
行かなかったら堂々と行かんぞと決めなさいよと
行きたいんだけど なんかだったらダメだと
男らしさも何もないんだと
だから言ったってもどうったことないんだから
行って勉強して たってもね
ろくなことはないよと
だからそんなに真剣になるなよと
そんな真剣に 何が問題あるでしょう
子供に 例えばもう年頃だからね
まあ女の子が友達にならないとかね
まあそんなもん ちょっとした子供の世界でちょっとしたトラブルがあると思いますし
そんなことはすぐ引き出すのはとっても簡単ですから
私にとってはね だから一回でも三十分で解決させます
三十分かかるのは向こうは話し下手だから
大体 だからそれには時間かかりますけど
こちらはささっとやりますからね
もう本人に会わせなさいとはっきり言ったところで
他の男の子を会わせてくれたんです
紹介した人々はやっぱりあなたも参加しちゃいけないと
そしたらみんな父親と友達の男性つけて
じゃあ二人だけに別のとこに行ったんですね
喫茶店で 別にそんな話の時にどうです？元気は何だ？そういう話で
それだけで問題解決したんだからね
では一つ約束した 私は私は君の話聞きますけど
一緒に瞑想しなきゃ聞いてあげないですと私と
それは別の話で それでまあ子供なりの話をいろいろ聞いて
それなりに言って まあそれすごい元気になっちゃって
では約束だから瞑想会に来いと
瞑想会に来て 瞑想 誰よりも真面目に瞑想もして
いたんだ 瞑想とあなたの問題はまた別の話
瞑想を指導する場合は
あなたは一人前で大人に扱いますよ
もう子供扱いしませんよと
気をつけろと だから言う通りにやれと
大人より真剣に瞑想もしましたし
で それっきりはもう何も問題はない
だから瞑想の結果では決してありません
ちょっと二 三分の話の結果なんです
ですから まあそれぐらい単純ですけど
この貪瞋痴に陥って勉強しなきゃどうしようか
仕事はどうしようかとかね
他人にどう言えばいいかと
そんなもんでしょうに
母親ってのは自分の見えで考えてるでしょうに
他のお母さんたちにどんな顔を見せればいいんです？自分が問題児扱ってるんだからと言って
鬼でしょうに そんなこと考えると
子供のこと心配していないでしょうに
自分の見栄のこと もし子供のことを心配して
あんた君学校に行きたくないの？だったら何か仕事でもやれ
それで終わるでしょうに
だって私たちはね もう年取るんだからね
君はもうそろそろ大人になって
私たちを養わなくちゃいけないんだからね
もう早く何か仕事をしなさいと
それで終わるでしょうに
だからもう解決する方
平和な世界にしたって
この貪瞋痴だけで考えて生きてるんだから
何一つも解決する方法はない世界なんですね
だからどんな専門家がしゃべったってのは
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ結論なしに終わる
精神科に見せた方が まあ見せた方がいいし
見せたって意味がないと
じゃあ薬 薬飲んだって飲まなく
そんなこと誰にでも言えることでしょう
どんな専門家もそういう結論では地震専門家と同じなんですよ
地震専門家っていうのは徹底的に研究はしてデータ取ってますけど
最新的な技術を全て持ってますけど
地震が起こるかないかと言えば我々と同じでしょ
だから地震の場合 悪口言えませんよ
いくら専門家であろうとも
やっぱり予言はできません
予言しようと努力するんだけど
それはできませんということは知ってるんだから
その人々には私は悪口は言いたくない
だから地震が起こりそうと言ったってのも
起こらなくたって まあそうということで
私は終わります そんな問題より当分起こらないんだよと言ったところで
ざっと地震起きちゃっても
別にそうですかねと それで終わっちゃいますけど
でも他の世界はそうじゃないでしょうに
だから予知できないのは地震だけなんですけど
どうですかね カウンセラーやら心理学者やらね
だから貪瞋痴の世界で貪瞋痴のみを正当化するために
だから医者も心理学者も誰でも経済学者も
この世界をどうやって金儲けて
もう自分が儲けて もうなんとかうまく生きるか
それしか考えてないでしょうに
だから智慧っていうのは一人も出てこないんですよ
何か質問出しちゃったら
じゃあそれを調べて研究して答え出しますと
質問したら答えればいいのに
やっぱり研究しなきゃ答えられないでしょうに
研究といったら過去の何かいじることだけでしょうに
ですから この人間に対して現れるほとんどの問題っていうのは妄想の問題なんですね
だから妄想の管理できれば大変やりがいことで
妄想の管理っていうのは
やっぱり貪瞋痴の次元の中でできるものじゃないんですね
そこは破らないと 全く違う思考っていうのは生まれてこないんです
人間 いくら考えたって全く同じ思考ではないかということで終わるんです
大胆な違う思考っていうのは
貪瞋痴を乗り越えない限りは出てこない
だから瞑想 これはお釈迦様はこの修行に使っている方法で
一般人に教えているものじゃないので
これはもう悟りたくて
もう一生懸命修行する人と俗世間を捨てて
もう次元を飛び出しちゃえと
もう心の次元が振りたいと一生懸命真面目に真剣に頑張っている修行者に言っていることなんですね
だから まあ俗世間にあまり言うのは
お釈迦様個人だったらあまり好ましくないんですね
だから仏教は この人と喋るために
人と争論するために かっこつけるために
知識人ぶるために勉強するものであって
仏教は心を清らかにするために
解脱するために勉強しますよと
という風にも言ってます
ですからまあ こちらではこの和士という
この乗り越えた人 いわゆるこの
すべて管理できる人 プロになった人がしたい思考する
したくない思考はしないと
それでアッチェッチ・タンハン
それいつできるかというと
タンハーが渇愛が切った時
断った時なんですね それで渇愛が断ちましたと
ビャーワッタイ・サンヨージャナ
この束縛をもうもう破ってしまったと
サンマー・マーナービ・サマヤ
サンマー より正しく マーナービ・サマヤ
マーン・マナというのは慢ですね
慢をアビサマヤ この乗り越えて
アンタン・アカーシ 終わりにしました
ドゥッカッセ 苦しみを
だから渇愛を断ちました
束縛を破れました マーナ
高慢をもうなくしたと
アビサマヤ なくなられるようにしてしまった
それで苦しみを終わりにしました
ここで仏教は ですから
苦しみをなくすためにあることで
ちゃんと結論で終わっちゃうんですね
目的を出してすごい厳密に整理して語っているんですね
ダラダラ話はないんです
同じことを何回も何回も繰り返してはくるんだけど
それは目的があって 暗記してほしいし
覚えてほしいし 強調するものは徹底的に強調しておく
ですから 回ぐらいは繰り返す
例えば嫌うということは
ちょっと強烈に言いたいんだから
三つ言うんですね デーグッチェティは最後ですけどね
アッティーエティハラエティ・デーグッチェティ
三つの言葉で言うというふうなシステム
それは言語学的なシステムで
でもちゃんと目的があって
ちゃんと結論で経典というのは終わってしまうんですね
厳密に思考を整理して喋っている
だからこの経典で言っているのは
そうやってこの妄想が生まれたらどうしようかっていう方法で
方法はいくつもですね
内容です